>> TOMORROW BE A MONTH SINCE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT LAUNCH
DOESN'T RUN AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
AND THE POLLS SUGGEST THAT
ELECTORS ARE TIRING.
AFTER A BRUTAL MIDTERMS FOR HIS
CHOSEN CANDIDATES, PLUS A
SERIES OF HEADLINES, MORE EAGER
FOR A STANDARD BEARER.
BUT NOT GOOD NEWS FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN EITHER BECAUSE VOTERS OF
ALL STRIPES AS WELL.
WHAT SHAWN KING.
>> I KNOW IT'S TOO EARLY FOR
MANY BUT CONSIDER THIS POLL A
BASELINE, AND THIS CLEAR
CONCLUSION.
VOTERS IN BOTH PARTIES CLEAR
MAJORITIES ARE LOOKING FOR
SOMEBODY NEW.
WE ASK REPUBLICANS AND
REPUBLICAN-LEANING AND YOU WANT
DONALD TRUMP TO BE THE NOMINEE
OF THE REPUBLICAN.
OR DO YOU WANT A DIFFERENT
CANDIDATE?
62%, MORE THAN 6:10 REPUBLICAN
SAY GIVE US SOMEBODY NEW PLAYS,
38% DONALD TRUMP WON SIX IN TEN
59% OF WE WOULD LIKE A NEW
CANDIDATE IN 2020 44 INTO NEVER
QUITE SAY LET'S STICK WITH THE
INCUMBENT DEMOCRAT WE HAVE.
AND SO WHAT, THOUGH, IF TRUMP
IS THE NOMINEE, WOULD
REPUBLICANS VOTE FOR HIM?
WELL, TWO THIRDS SAY YES.
THAT IS SIGNIFICANT, THOUGH.
DOESN'T MEAN THIS WOULD STICK
FOR TWO YEARS.
BUT 32% REPUBLICAN SAY NO, THAT
LEAVES AN OPENING FOR DEMOCRATS
TO GET THOSE VOTES.
BUT TWO THIRDS SAY AS.
ON THIS QUESTION, ANDERSON, JOE
BIDEN'S FARE BETTER.
66 FOR TRUMP, 78% FOR DEMOCRATS
SAY BUT IF JOE BIDEN IS OUR
NOMINEE FOR 2024 WE WILL VOTE
TO REELECT.
NEARLY ANTIDEMOCRATIC SAY THAT
IN 22% SAY NO.
SO WHAT IS ABOUT YOUR
TRAJECTORY?
HOW ARE YOU AND IN THE AIR
COMPARED TO HOW YOU BEGAN THE
YEAR?
LET'S START WITH THE PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS IN BETTER
SHAPE AT.
THE BEGINNING THE LEADER HE WAS
A 45%.
THEN IN JULY HE DIPPED TO 25%.
HERE IN DECEMBER, 40% OF
DEMOCRATS SAY HE SHOULD BE THE
NOMINEE.
NOT AS STRONG AS HE WAS TO OPEN
THE YEAR, BUT STRONGER THAN HE
WAS IN THE SUMMERTIME.
IT IS THE FLIP SIDE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS FROM THE TRUMP
QUESTION.
AT THE BEGINNING OF 2022, 50%
OF REPUBLICANS SAY WE WANT
DONALD TRUMP IS OUR NOMINEE.
THAT DROP TO 44% IN JULY.
IT IS NOW DOWN TO 38%.
THE TRAJECTORY FOR TRUMP IS
HEADING IN THE WRONG DIRECTION.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS STABILIZED
SOME.
NOW IF YOUR NAME IS SOMEONE
BESIDES TRUMP, YOU ARE IN
STRONG SHAPE IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARIES.
IT'S A JOKE, BUT LOOK AT THE
POLL.
32% NEVER PUBLIC AND LEANING
VOTERS SAY WE WANT SOMEBODY
BESIDES TRUMP.
THEY'RE OPEN MINDED AS TO HOW
IT SHOULD BE, NO DOUBT THOUGH,
ANDERSON IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
POLL AND OTHER POLLING OUT
THERE.
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS,
IF IT'S NOT TRUMP, RON DESANTIS
IN THE STRONGEST POSITION AT
THIS IS EARLY DAY, ABOUT 30% OF
REPUBLICAN LEADING VOTERS
TEHRAN DESANTIS, NOBODY ELSE.
NOBODY ELSE GETS EVEN CLOSE.
ALMOST NOT WORTH CONSIDERING.
MITT ROMNEY TED CRUZ RAN BEFORE
MAKING, HEALY FORMER SOUTH
CAROLINA GOVERNOR TRANSCEND
THIS ACID OR, ALL AT 1%.
SO RHONDA SANTA HAS A
COMMANDING POSITION AT THIS
EARLY STAGE, UNLESS SOMEONE
BESIDES TRUMP GETS IN THE
REPUBLICAN RACE.
ANDERSON?
>> KING, ARE PERCEPTIVE FROM
OUR CHIEF POLITICAL ANALYSTS
AND FORMER CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL AND
COMMENTATOR SCOTT JENNINGS,
FORMER ASSISTANT TO GEORGE W.
BUSH.
AT THE BOTTOM LINE FROM THE
POLE IS A LITTLE APPETITE FOR
2020 REMATCH BIDEN STILL THAT
CAN OBVIOUSLY HAPPEN.
>> I'LL SAY.
LOOK, FIRST WE SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT BOTH OF THESE MEN ARE VERY
POPULAR IN THEIR OWN PARTY.
AND SO THE DEMOCRATS STILL LIKE
JOE BIDEN, IF HE RUNS, AND
DONALD TRUMP HAS A VERY STRONG
BASE IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY,
BUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO PARTIES, AS JOHN WAS JUST
SHOWING YOU, IS THAT
REPUBLICANS FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
A SOLID ALTERNATIVE.
THAT ALTERNATIVE IS RHONDA
SANTAS, BUT WHEN YOU ASKED
DEMOCRATS IF NOT JOE BIDEN THEN
WHO, 72% OF THEM SAID THEY HAD
NO PARTICULAR FAVORITE.
SO THEY DON'T KNOW WHO TO TURN
TO THEIR.
NOT SAYING KAMALA HARRIS, FOR
EXAMPLE.
THEY'RE KIND OF SEEING MAYBE
THIS PERSON OR MAYBE THAT
PERSON.
SO THAT IS REALLY GOOD,
ACTUALLY, FOR JOE BIDEN,
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING WELL, WHO ELSE IS THEY
ARE OUT THERE THAT WE WOULD
REALLY BE AS ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT?
THE ANSWER IS, WE DON'T KNOW.
>> SCOTT, I KNOW YOU THINK SOME
OF THE CHANGES AMONG
REPUBLICANS ON THE SUPPORT FOR
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, WHICH
APPEARS TO BE REFLECTED IN THIS
POLL, DUTIES REPRESENTS A
PERMANENT SHIFT?
.
I DO >> I THINK IT'S A
CONTINUING SHIFT.
I THINK YOU REALLY CONTINUE TO
SEE THIS CHANGE.
WHAT'S REMARKABLE IS THAT
RHONDA SENTENCE HASN'T HAD TO
DO MUCH OF ANYTHING OTHER THAN
WIN REELECTION AND CONVINCING
FASHION.
DONALD TRUMP ANNOUNCED THE
CAMPAIGN AND HAS BEEN OUT THERE
TALKING ON HIS OWN BEHALF, AND
IT IS GETTING WORSE AND WORSE
AND WORSE WHILE DESANTIS IS
GETTING BETTER AND BETTER.
SO THE EFFORT THAT TRUMP IS
HAVING TO EXPAND IS NOT
TRANSLATING INTO SUPPORT.
THE NUMBER THAT JUMPED OUT OF
ME IN THE POLL WAS 32% OF
REPUBLICANS WHO SAID THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO BACK TRUMP IF HE
WERE THE NOMINEE IN 2024.
I THINK A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE
WOULD GO HOME EVENTUALLY, BUT
IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT HOW WEAK
TRUMP WOULD BE AS A ELECTION
CANDIDATE.
IF DEMOCRATS PICK OFF JUST A
FEW REPUBLICANS IN KEY STATES
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW, GEORGIA,
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE SENATE RACE, IT MAKES IT
EASY FOR A DEMOCRAT TO WIN IN A
PURPLE STATE, SO, YOU SEE,
CRACKS, AMONG REPUBLICANS, BUT
YOU ALSO SEE THE PLAIN TRUTH.
IF WE NOMINATE TRUMP THEY
NOMINATE BIDEN, REPUBLICANS ARE
GONNA LOSE IF THE.
REPUBLICANS NOMINATE SOMEONE
YOU, WE HAVE A MUCH BETTER
CHANCE.
>> KIRSTEN, DO YOU AGREE WITH
THAT?
IF REPUBLICANS NOMINATED,
WHETHER IT'S DESANTIS OR
SOMEBODY KNEW, THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE A BETTER CHANCE TO WIN
THAN THE DEMOCRATS WOULD BE
RUNNING JOE BIDEN IN THAT CASE,
PRESUMABLY?
>> YEAH.
I THINK SO.
AND I THINK THE OTHER THING
THAT WAS IN THE POLLS SHOW THAT
WAS HOW BIDEN AND TRUMP ARE
BOTH PERCEIVED, WHERE YOU HAVE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF VOTERS
SAYING THEY SEE BIDEN IS BEING
A PRETTY MAINSTREAM PERSON AND
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
SEEING DONALD TRUMP AS BEING,
AS HAVING VERY EXTREME VIEWS,
AND IT'S BECAUSE THE VOTERS
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
GET, YOU'RE GONNA GET YOUR BASE
VOTERS.
I DO THINK PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
ENTHUSIASTIC RIGHT NOW AND IT
BECOMES A HEAD TO HEAD MATCH.
YOU HAVE A BIDEN VERSUS TRUMP.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO SHOW UP
FOR THAT.
THAT WILL BE THE MOTIVATOR.
THEY WILL GET MORE ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT BIDEN.
AND SO I THINK THE FACT THAT
YOU CAN SEE THAT BIDEN IS SO
MUCH MORE ACCEPTABLE TO MORE
MODERATE VOTERS, TO MORE
INDEPENDENT VOTERS IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE JUST SEEING HIM AS BEING
A MAINSTREAM PERSON VERSUS
THOSE VOTERS LOOKING AT TRUMP
AND SAYING HE SEEMED TO
EXTREME.
>> GLORIA, HOW BIG A PROBLEM IS
IT FOR DEMOCRATS THAT THERE
ISN'T A RHONDA SANCHEZ-LIKE
FIGURE OTHER THAN JOE BIDEN?
IF BIDEN RUNS, OBVIOUSLY,
THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM, BUT IF HE
DOESN'T RUN, HOW BIG A DEAL IS?
IT >> IT'S A PROBLEM.
I THINK IT'S A REAL PROBLEM
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ANY
GROUNDSWELL FOR ANYONE.
AND YOU KNOW IN THESE
SITUATIONS, ANDERSON,
CANDIDATES COME OUT OF THE
WOODWORK.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT
NATIONAL DEMOCRATS OUT THERE,
BUT SO FAR WE HAVEN'T HEARD
PEOPLE SCREAMING OH I'M GOING
TO CHALLENGE JOE BIDEN IF HE
DECIDES TO RUN.
THERE ARE A LOT OF WHISPERS
ABOUT, IT OBVIOUSLY, A LOT OF
WHISPERS ABOUT HIS AGE, AND
THAT'S CLEARLY GETTING ON HIS
NERVES.
I CAN TELL YOU WHAT'S GETTING
ON THE NERVES OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR HIM.
BUT THERE ISN'T ANYBODY SAYING
TED KENNEDY DID WITH JIMMY
CARTER, I'M GONNA GO OUT THERE
AND I'M GOING TO CHALLENGE HIM,
BECAUSE THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS, THAT MOST RANK AND FILE
DEMOCRATS LIKE JOE BIDEN AND
THEY BELIEVE HE HAS DONE A LOT
AND ACCOMPLISHED A LOT, AND SO
THAT WOULD BE A HARD RECORD FOR
THEM TO RUN AGAINST.
>> SCOTT, DO YOU THINK THERE'S
ANY CHANCE THAT JOE BIDEN WOULD
NOT HAVE KAMALA HARRIS AS HIS
RUNNING MATE?
>> NO CHANCE AT ALL.
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK OF JOE
BIDEN WANTS TO BE HIS PARTY'S
NOMINEE HE'S GOING TO BE,
REGARDLESS OF THE SOFTNESS OF
NUMBERS, HE'S THE SITTING
PRESIDENT AND HE'S GONNA BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
I THINK HARRIS WILL BE HIS
RUNNING MATE.
I THINK REPUBLICANS SHOULD PLAN
FOR THAT.
I THINK TRUMP IS IN A MUCH
WEAKER POSITION BECAUSE HE'S
NOT THE SITTING PRESIDENT, AND
WE'VE ALREADY RUN HIM TWICE AND
LOST THE NATIONAL POPULAR VOTE
TWICE, AND ONE ARGUMENT BIDEN
HAS IS THAT HE WON THE NATIONAL
POPULAR VOTE.
THAT'S NOTHING TO SNIFF AT IN
THIS DAY AND AGE.
I REALLY DO THINK BIDEN IS
PRETTY MUCH A LOCK IF YOU JUST
AS I'M RUNNING, AND I THINK
TRUMP IS IN A MUCH WEAKER
POSITION VIS-À-VIS HIS OWN
PARTY BECAUSE HE HAS HIS TRACK
RECORD OF NOT GETTING MORE
VOTES THAN A DEMOCRAT.
>> KIRSTEN, DOES IT FEEL TO YOU
LIKE DONALD TRUMP IS ACTUALLY
RUNNING?
HE MADE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT A
MONTH AGO AND THEN OTHER THAN
HAD LUNCH WITH ANTISEMITES AND
VARIOUS DISREPUTABLE CHARACTERS,
HASN'T REALLY DONE ANYTHING.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE'S OUT BUILDING
HOUSES FOR HABITAT HUMANITY.
HE'S NOT DOING ANYTHING.
>> I WOULDN'T HOLD YOUR BREATH
FOR THAT ONE.
LOOK, WE'RE STILL ACTUALLY
PRETTY FAR OUT.
WHY HE DECIDED TO ANNOUNCE WHEN
HE ANNOUNCED, LOTS OF PEOPLE
HAVE DIFFERENT THEORIES ABOUT
THAT.
BUT I THINK THAT WE COULD EVEN
THINK ABOUT HIS CAMPAIGN LAST
TIME.
IT MOSTLY WAS HIM GETTING FREE
MEDIA DOING HIS EVENTS AND HE'S
NOT GOING TO GET THAT RIGHT
NOW.
AND HE'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
GET EVEN DOWN THE ROAD.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A BIG CAMPAIGN,
AND ALL THE REPORTS ARE HE
WANTS TO HAVE A SMALLER
CAMPAIGN THAN HE HAD LAST TIME.
I THINK THAT THE SUBSTANCE OF
THE CAMPAI